I think that there's a decent argument
to be made that AI is sort of like the
next thing with intelligence creation
it's like genes and then it's memes and
then like what's next there's an
argument to be made in the e-act dudes
would surely make this argument which is
that AI is a new way of categorizing
information and a new way of gaining
information and basically a new way to
pass it on today in our like meme world
or whatever like in order for me to
teach a lesson to my kid I have to like
say the words to them or like give them
a book that has a written down or
whatever probably one of those two
things in the future when we have openai
at scale or whatever we have like chat
GPT seven or like whatever we don't have
to deliberately go find that information
and pass it down anymore the computers
will basically pass it down for us
all right guys bang bang I've got
Christian here with me uh today's entire
conversation is around effective
accelerationism and it's this brand new
movement that's kind of taking the tech
World by storm there's lots of people
who are supporters lots of people who
are critics and I thought Christian uh
had a bunch of content that he put out
online that really kind of laid out what
is it why is it important and why should
people uh think about supporting a kind
of this entire movement so Christian
maybe we could just start with like what
is effective accelerationism absolutely
yeah thanks for having me on so
effective accelerationism is a lot of
different things that are combined into
one which I think is sort of inevitable
with this sort of internet meme that has
taken on a life of its own I think you
saw if you looked it in the very early
days it was sort of a response to
effective altruism which was this belief
that you could take about a money and
you could allocate it correctly to make
the things that you want to happen in
the world happen
um the IAC movement started as saying
well if you take that logic and apply it
to AI then we're going to you know be
very very uh directed we're going to be
very controlled in in terms of what we
want to do we're going to take it slow
we're going to take the right steps at
the right times but EAC is the opposite
of that they say just let a thousand
flowers bloom let's try everything let's
see what works and see what doesn't and
uh and therefore it's the Techno Capital
machine will take care of it for you
it'll just you know we'll we'll gradient
descend our way into the right outcomes
as opposed to predetermining them ahead
of time so
um that was the the beginning was sort
of this movement that was focused on AI
and it was focused on you know let's let
ai go and not try to control it
um I think that recently you've seen it
take on more of a kind of
all-encompassing role within the the
Twitter world where it's kind of a
banner for accelerationism as a whole so
rather than it being just a specific AI
thing or just a specific you know
utilitarianism thing it's about how do
we accelerate technology how do we make
it so that you know uh we create the
world that we want to create well we do
that by letting the reins loose and
letting people take it wherever they
want to go one of the pieces that uh
cracked me up early on is
um it just seems like it's free market
right like at the end of the day
accelerationism is like let people do
what they want to do and allow them to
figure out how to solve people's
problems and it seems like the folks who
are anti-free Market anti kind of
competition they tend to be the doomers
right they're the ones who are like wait
everyone slow down like the world is
going to get worse or there's some huge
problem that looms uh you know on the
horizon whereas this whole like
effective accelerationism is just
basically taking the idea of a free
market and now saying look let's bring
it to the tech world put it on steroids
and like let's roll
yeah I mean uh this has happened for
hundreds of years I mean like I think uh
your audience would know this like back
in the uh this is a classic example used
by folks that are folks uh proponents of
crypto uh the red flag loss you ever
heard of that whereas back of the
creation the automobile like they were
afraid of the automobiles rolling
through town and like hitting kids or
something and so the strategy was they
can't go any faster than a horse
whenever any automobile goes through
town it has to have this red flag that's
waved down in front of it says watch out
and Automobiles coming like that's one
way to make sure that people are safe
from automobiles another way is to
invent your way out of it to invent seat
belts to invent you know Road lines to
invent stop signs to invent traffic
enforcement so
um I think that I mean this has been
happening forever it is interesting that
the this specific movement IAC has
broadened the way it has I think uh
that's sort of a symptom of when you get
a ton of different people contributing
to a move into kind of uh you know
dilutes it down to just its core
elements and so I think that that is one
of the reasons why my post about eak
went so well is because I sort of
identified what are those core elements
and to me me it's really three things it
is a belief that things can get better
over time not that they will but that
they can the second one is that
technology can make things better so
technology has a force for making the
world the way we want to make it and
then the final one which I think is
actually maybe the most important is
individual agency so just the belief
that you personally could have a say in
making this world come about and if you
personally do something then things can
happen that's like that is the Silicon
Valley ethos at its most Central and so
that's why I think people you know like
Mark Andreessen like Gary tan like these
very uh seminal figures in Silicon
Valley have latched on to eax so hard
it's because it's just the perfect like
hacker I can do this let's change the
world mindset so the three things you
just said don't sound that crazy
individually but obviously there are uh
controversy and critics around uh kind
of this effective accelerationism and so
let's just take the first one of like
things can get better is there evidence
that that hasn't happened in history
like have there been things where sure
on on maybe a small vertical or one
piece of Life yes it didn't get better
over some period of time but overall
humans live at the safest most
prosperous time in human history and
like the best time to be born is
literally today the next best time to be
born would be like yesterday right so
sorry yeah yeah it's just kind of like
uh yeah of course you want to be born as
far into the future as possible because
the world's only gonna uh seems to be
only getting better what is so
controversial about that idea of like
the world could get better
I think um so if you were if you're
truly trying to like steal them in this
and trying to make the case against like
how could the world get worse I think
there's sort of two arguments to it um
the first argument is really simple
which is we just don't know like it we
have no idea what the future will hold
so it could go this way and it could go
that way it could be greater could be
horrible
um if we're unleashing a new power out
into the world which is kind of how
people think of AI now it's this new
thing didn't exist before it has immense
capability
um who knows what it's going to do if
it's more intelligent than us if it's
this artificial general intelligence
that's super intelligent who are we to
say what it's going to do it's smarter
than us by definition
um so that's sort of one argument which
is just an argument from uncertainty I
think the the historical argument that
people would point to is that there have
been times in the past where we've like
lost knowledge or we've lost order I
think like the simplest example of that
is the Dark Ages like we went from
whatever Roman Empire glorious golden
age to this this era where basically
like nothing was written down like
historians don't even know what was
happening in the Dark Ages because
civilization kind of went into this uh
you know but this Lower State this worst
state than it was that was at before so
I think that
um there are arguments that could say we
could get worse but I agree with you 100
that you know this is the best time to
be alive we have the general trajectory
of the universe has been towards things
being great
um and so yeah especially you know over
the past 100 years over the past 50
years over the past 10 years we've been
seeing this exponential increase in the
amount of Technology that's being built
and
um I think it all just Builds on each
other obviously now that we've
discovered you know glass we can make
iPhone touch screens now that we've
discovered electricity we can create
however many types of new things these
Innovations build on each other and I
think the IAC argument would be that AI
is this new building block that is going
to unlock an
unfathomable amount of new innovation
that we've never seen before so going to
technology can make the world a better
place uh or kind of help us build the
world we want to be not even just a
better place which I think now is kind
of this like terminology that people
laugh at but also uh there's like a hint
of Truth in it
um again it seems like history would
suggest that that is exactly what
happens over and over and over again is
technology and again technology could
literally be like shoes on your feet
right like I always go back to this idea
of people think technology has to be AI
or it has to be you know some uh amazing
uh quantum computer or you know some
genomic sequencing like yes that is
technology but also we are talking about
literally basic things like a belt to
hold your pants up right the shoes on
your feet to not you know uh kind of
ruin your feet when you walk around like
these things are all technologies that
we grew up they were just a part of life
and we don't really put that much kind
of value on them today but man there's a
lot of people around the world that wear
shoes and belts right and so kind of
talk talk a little bit it's like what is
the counter argument or like why is that
controversial
yeah I mean I think so um you tell me
how far down this Rabbit Hole you want
to go to the bottom to the bottom okay
great so
um in my mind technology goes way way
way more basic than even that so yeah
like belts or whatever it doesn't have
Electronics in it but it's still
technology I think ideas are also
technology and if you think about it
like the furthest back that you can go
the first way that we ever like we
meaning like life or we meaning kind of
the universe the first way that the
Universe ever made sense of what was
around it was genetic material so genes
and you could argue were the first
technology it was the first way that the
world captured information and was able
to store it and pass it down in kind of
its own finite Bunch so
um you know that was captured of course
in DNA in a replicator in a replicating
molecule that took in information from
the environment and then passed it down
to the Next Generation some of that
information was really helpful so you
know if you're a Proto DNA whatever like
maybe you encode the information into
your DNA that hey there are seeds out
here in the environment
um maybe you encode the information hey
there's there's nothing out there
there's no food we can't we're doomed
we're dead there's nothing we can do
um which of those two genes do you think
was more likely to survive in the future
the one that gave true helpful
information to the Next Generation so
that was the first technology that
allowed sort of you know um growth to
happen that allowed uh you know Excel
well acceleration that allowed
information to get passed down from one
generation to the next which then
accelerated over time to create these
super elaborate creatures these uh you
know these amazing civilizations and
communities and then ultimately humans
um and that was the emergence of what we
think of as technology which is you know
deliberately passing down those lessons
or those uh pieces of knowledge down to
the Next Generation so I mean what is
what is that technology what is a belt
belt is an idea a belt is an idea that
says if you take a strip of something
and you've tied around your waist then
you can you know hold up your pants like
uh what are shoes shoes is the idea that
if you strap something to your feet then
you're not going to get hurt as much and
maybe you're going to live longer and
maybe you can travel further so
um the the first wave was genes the
second wave was memes memes are just
ideas that replicate there are ideas
that are passed down from generation to
generation and really it's much faster
than that you know a gene only
replicates once per somebody having a
baby
um a meme replicates you know today's
speed like how fast what like there's
been multiple different movements in the
past week on our in our part of Twitter
that we've been talking about you know
these superconductors we've been talking
about uh you know uh the yeah everything
so memes replicate much faster than
genes and that's the new kind of
technology that is you know propelling
us forth so as we look at this like you
know take something like Facebook I
worked there uh in the early 2010s and
one of the uh big kind of debates was
like is Facebook good for the world or
not right and at the time like I think
most people would say yes and then it
kind of changed over time and I just
always laughed to myself I'm like wait a
minute hold on a second like there's
definitely downsides like people will
use tools to do bad things right there's
guns that can save lives there's guns
that can kill people and so like uh the
tools sometimes can be used for good or
bad and doesn't necessarily mean the
tool itself is good or bad but something
like a Facebook uh I I used to just
crack up because I'm like wait we've
connected billions literally Facebook
today has two billion daily active users
that are able to communicate with
friends and family and learn and do you
know message each other like do all this
stuff and what we do is we almost like
go as a society we look for like what's
the one bad negative thing and then just
like blow that up like see I told you
it's bad and like again that doesn't
mean that that bad thing it should like
not be called out or not be critiqued
but it's looking at things on a totality
and we almost take the good stuff for
granted because it's like you know I'm
complaining on Twitter about this thing
that Twitter is doing and you're like
hey Genius Like pay attention right and
so is that just human nature or is that
something that is unique to maybe like
the tech industry today where like the
proponents and the critics uh have
almost like lost the uh idea of like
Tech enables the conversation and the
debate which is actually a key piece of
it no I mean you see that in like
politics and everything too like the
famous quote of like what is
conservatism is people standing authored
history and yelling stop you know what I
mean like that like they're they're that
there's that sort of energy everywhere
and I think honestly it's sort of
healthy it's like you know you want some
people to be restraining you want other
people to be pushing forward if we went
pure unadulterated chaos mode like we
wouldn't ever build order and that's
ultimately the goal of what technology
is it's order that we're passing down
from generation to generation so yes we
need to try like a million different
things but then ultimately we need to
find some that are good to pass on to
the next Generation I mean I I 100 agree
with you about the the people picking
out the the small parts of technology
and using that as a you know trying to
defeat the whole thing
um the example that really is personal
to me is the internet
um my company builds internet satellites
and so we're helping bring internet to
people all over the world you know one
satellite and one country at a time and
I've actually had friends come to me and
they like they are sort of joking but
they're sort of not they're like do we
want to bring in the internet like is it
better for people to be on the Internet
or are they just going to get you know
exposed all the the uh the internet mobs
or whatever like the the downsides of
the internet
um and to me it's just so obvious it's
like well sure maybe if you're super
inundated like oversaturated with
internet if you take anything to its
extreme to too much of anything is
always too much like you know what I
mean but
um these people that are first getting
on the Internet and using it for the
first time they're not using it to like
you know yell at their neighbors on next
door or like whatever on these on these
apps they're using it to get access to
healthcare they're using it to get
access to uh education like the basics
are incredibly important and ignore and
saying that people shouldn't have the
basics because eventually someday really
far down the line someone could use too
much of this technology that doesn't
make any sense to me so the first point
is like the world can get better the
second is that technology can be a great
uh vessel for that Improvement that
Innovation the third though is
individual agency and this one I mean we
have two completely different
populations in this world today we have
people who literally think that the
government is going to come save them
and they don't need to do anything uh
and then we've got a portion of the
population who's like literally everyone
get out of my way and I will take uh
kind of the ball and I'll run with it uh
individual agency is a key component and
we need it for uh effective
accelerationism or is it something that
like it's a nice to have as part of the
movement
um so I think you would find two
different camps of people that would
argue both sides of that within the
movement which is which is again great
it makes the movement better everybody
has their own idea of it that's their
their kind of a meta movement that says
you should figure out your own thing
um but I would say there were two
arguments so the first argument is yes
individual people matter we like we're
the only people that can bring about the
change like we have to go invent
everything like the individual agency
the kind of is core to Silicon Valley
um but I think you would probably also
find people on the other side of that
argument which would basically say as
long as people are allowed to go
experiment no individual person is
necessary to the the success of the
machine and that that really
um is an important point to them to the
EAC folks they believe that the machine
takes care of itself they don't think
it's like my job or pump's job or
whatever to decide how we move the
machine how you know the this the arm
can go up in this way and the leg can
move that way like they don't think that
it's any one person's job to actually
I'd like operate the entire machine that
is capitalism that is you know all of us
creating a new ideas together
um they believe that the machine does
that itself so I think it's sort of you
asked the question right at the border
of where you know yes each individual
person has to go out and experiment and
do their own thing and figure out the
way forward but no individual person
should control the whole machine because
they just don't there's nobody that
knows that much no one's going to make
good decisions for a hundred years or
two hundred years or a thousand years in
the future so when you mention machine I
think a lot of people have heard the
terminology techno Capital machine uh it
scares the [__] out of some of them and
it gets them some others really really
excited what is the Techno Capital
machine
it's Transformers it's just Optimus
Prime it's just
no it's uh so the technical Capital
machine is basically a word um for how
does the economy and society as a whole
allocate stuff how do we allocate our
time how do we allocate our resources
um and how do we you know come up with
new ideas to solve new problems that's
that's all it is it's like this
um it's sort of like this meta organism
like this thing this like uh this
combination of all the different people
that are all acting on their own
individual agency so
um I think it's funny because a lot of
these people that work are like that
think about eak work at like open Ai and
these other AI companies that are
debatably literally trying to create
that Optimus Prime like uh meta organism
thing but uh no they're just talking
about Society it's like a fancy word for
society you also said that IAC is kind
of the fight against entropy right and
what I think is so interesting about
that is
um
are the doomers or the like degrothers
like are they literally we should just
pause like just freeze the Earth today
don't develop new technology don't solve
problems like uh we're too scared I
almost think of like helicopter parents
right like I'm too scared to let my kid
go outside because they may possibly
fall and scrape their knee versus the
parents who are literally kicking their
kids out of the house during the summer
and like locking the door like come back
for dinner uh it like what is the end
goal for the D growth or the like the
Doomer type movement
um I think the the Doomer argument is
let's wait until we figure it out like
let's not let's not unleash a power we
don't understand I think the the problem
with that is that you know first of all
we almost never understand things before
we invent them I think this is that's
actually like a definition of invention
if you ask me like if you knew what it
was before you invented it then you
already invented it that's like it's one
of my favorite authors of all time is
Alistair McIntyre and he writes about
that he says like I think he's actually
quoting Carl popper who who originally
said or something but anyways the
examples of a wheel it's like if me and
you are sitting in the Stone Age and
we're trying to just like come up with
cool stuff around the campfire and I'm
like dude I have that I think that
there's this idea uh about like I don't
know it's like a circle and then if we
attach to a cart then maybe we could
like roll the card easier and you're
like well you say what is it I say oh
like I don't know yet it hasn't been
invented like that doesn't exist like
the like the very Act of describing the
thing is inventing it so if we fully
understood like what these future
systems would be then we would have to
already have made them like we're not
going to be able to predict what's kind
of coming up in the future so it's sort
of a self feeding it says we have to
lock in exactly where we are today
because that's all we can understand
let's fully get there before we can move
forward
um but I don't think that's how the
world works I don't think that you know
I don't think your kid's going to grow
up to be a great kid if you just like
strapped indoor like you know strapped
to a chair indoors all day because
that's like the safest place you can
possibly be I think
um uh the the word entropy basically
means the intrinsic Direction uh of
something so and everything is trending
towards disorder that's how everything
works in the world you know you unplug
your fridge it's not getting any new
energy anymore so all of a sudden it
just becomes room temperature everything
is evening out stars are burning out
over time you know the pot on your stove
stops boiling if you turn off the gas
um everything evens out everything goes
to you know inert uniform nothingness
over time that's what entropy means
um but what that implies is that if you
just stop if you stop making progress if
you stop accelerating if you just go
constantly in the future you're gonna
you're gonna disintegrate into Dark Ages
like that's how dark ages happen is you
stop making progress you try to stay
even you try to say even healed
um that's that's how you end up letting
entropy take over it's just it slowly
degrades everything as you're just
sitting there trying to maintain
how important is it to have a movement
that people feel a part of like one of
the things that uh we've seen you know
through centuries and centuries is the
importance of religion as an example uh
then if you look at things like in the
Bitcoin and crypto Community there's
like this tribalism and everyone kind of
wants like a flag to wave right in
sports we see like your team uh I
recently read a thing that uh Ben
Affleck who uh Affleck who's a um a huge
Boston Red Sox fan in a movie they
wanted him to wear a New York Yankees
hat and he refused and they literally
had a shutdown uh uh filming and the
like
um uh kind of uh you know conclusion was
we'll meet halfway I'll wear a Mets hat
but I'm not putting on the Yankees hat
and so like like people have this like
identity right they get tied into this
stuff in the tech industry
I don't maybe there really hasn't been
one other than like hey I'm like part of
Silicon Valley like whatever that meant
but is this really like the first major
movement where people are saying like
let's put the flag up and kind of like
just go Take On the World with
technology problem solving skills and
Entrepreneurship uh entrepreneurship and
like we think we can build this better
world
I think that it's it's interesting I
think you're finding uh that this is an
example of us getting better and better
technology over time like this the EF
movement in my mind is the current
Pinnacle but there'll be something else
like there's going to be another better
way to for us to figure out how to
describe technology describe what we're
doing but we're we're improving we're
improving our technology at the same
time that we're improving the meme which
is how do we describe Silicon Valley and
try to encapsulate what we're doing I
mean I moved to Silicon Valley I guess
it was like seven or eight years ago now
um and when I joined there wasn't all
that much to find in terms of like
resources that it would explain how
Silicon Valley works and what is Silicon
Valley and what's like the the Mantra
and the mindset and everything like that
um I eventually found my way to you know
Y combinator and like why competitor has
these great like startup like how to
build a startup lectures Sam Altman um
CEO of openai actually was a person who
quit that on his personal website later
became the president of Y combinator and
it's now the CEO he's now the CEO of
open AI he's in open Ai and World coin
and a bunch of other projects that your
listeners probably know about
um and there but when I was there that
like that was sort of the only resource
like there wasn't a lot that I could
latch on to and figure out I knew there
was something out in Silicon Valley but
I didn't really know what
um and over time over the years that
I've been here I've learned that or I've
seen we're getting much better as
Silicon Valley about talking about
ourselves and explaining what it is that
Silicon Valley does I mean I I spent you
know the last two years or something
doing this this newsletter called
Silicon Valley Outsider which was
basically this idea like how do you take
this uh this thing Silicon Valley and
explain it to someone who's outside of
it who's never heard of any of this Tech
stuff maybe they only know it from
Instagram and Snapchat on their phone
um so we've gotten better and iak I
think is the current Pinnacle of like
what is Silicon Valley like Silicon
Valley to me is that individual optimism
that technology can do anything attitude
uh and all that and you know it comes
with a lot of thermodynamics and like
other kind of crazy stuff too uh which
is really fun and like super cool to
think about but um we're gonna have
other movements that encapsulate Silicon
Valley our memes are going to improve
our time too I've always thought that uh
the tech industry in general one of the
things that they've done very well is
solve problems right you know if you
look at Uber like for all of the kind of
[__] that Uber got over the years uh at
the end of the day like you press a
button on your phone and the car shows
up sure you can complain about the price
you can complain about what the car is
you can complain about uh how the
company is structured the price the
profitability you can complain about the
driver treatment like there's a whole
bunch of stuff that they probably could
improve but at the end of the day the
core idea of like press a button on your
phone a car shows up that's [__] cool
right and it solved a problem and so
like how you know to me the tech
industry has always just been like
people who are trying to solve problems
and you mentioned why combinator like
literally like that's almost like the
motto right it's just like build [__]
that people want and if you do that like
you can build a company and so is that
the story that needs to be told is like
just like hey this is a group of people
who just want to solve these problems
and by the way a way to do it is this
like free market you know kind of
structure of you know accelerate just
like everyone go faster and go bigger
and just push these Technologies to the
Limit and we will discover ways to solve
it and yes some of it won't work but
like that's okay
yeah exactly I mean I the thing that
originally got me interested in all the
stuff that led me to eact and led me to
all this accelerationism was the idea of
asymmetries and I think that Silicon
Valley is built on one extremely key
asymmetry which is limited downside
unlimited upside it's the idea that you
can put in you know a year of your time
or four years of your time you can put
in however many millions of dollars from
outside investors and the worst that
could happen the absolute worst is that
it's worth zero dollars and you sort of
you know you're wasting your time you
didn't get any more than just your
salary when you went out there to work
um but the upside of these Technologies
is like changing the world like uh you
yeah your joke or we all joke that you
know even it was in the Silicon Valley
TV show like we're building like
back-end ml models that'll change the
world or whatever but uh I think it's I
think like a lot of the recent
technology that you've seen all these
like Hardware projects and all this like
AI stuff like these things really do
have the potential to make a huge impact
on everyday life around the world
um and it's cool I think I think it's
very cool that uh you see that um you
see that like kind of progression taking
place uh over time you mentioned earlier
that uh the tech industry is getting
better at the memes and I think you know
obviously with Twitter we've seen that
happen uh in things kind of going viral
but now what we're starting to see is
almost that it used to be like our work
will speak for itself
but that isn't how the world works like
if you don't tell your story then
someone else will and so is effective
accelerationism is that really a
response to the doomers or is that more
of us saying look let's just come up
with something that can describe a point
of view of the world put a banner on it
and then just put it out there so that
when people ask well what are those
people trying to do it kind of comes in
a more tidy you know package or is it
literally just like doomers think that
AI is going to ruin the world so like we
got to come up with something to uh to
push back on them
deliver it I think it was much more
emergent than it was deliberate it was
people that were I mean it started with
Anonymous dudes on Twitter who just you
know they're posting Behind these
pictures like their profile pictures
like an eagle and they're like they have
some name that's like uh like you know
Jeff Bezos but Beth Jesus like as these
guys that were Anonymous on Twitter and
working with these really cool companies
like open Ai and like super ridiculously
smart but just wanted to you know shoot
the [__] with their friends on Twitter
spaces and so they started doing these
things and they started talking more and
more and they got more and more of a
little audience that was going and then
over time this like emergent thing came
out of it which was iak which was like
we're not going to be effective uh you
know Ultra risk we're going to be
effective accelerationists we don't
think that we can just determine what's
right ahead of time we're going to
figure it out as we go along so
um I don't think like the the Council of
Twitter anons like sat down and you know
had the one meeting where they decided
like hey you asked the answer but it
just kind of happened over time as the
as the meme took off the meme took on a
life of its own so as these people are
posting more and more becoming more
popular I think people are figuring out
who they are and I know the identities
of some of them and like they're super
legit people right these are not like
like for all the [__] posting that's
going on and I think at first people
were like you know who's this person
just kind of [__] posting on Twitter now
also they're like wait a minute like I
know who that person is and I see the
[__] posting and like man there's a lot
of validity to what they're saying but
the fact that it didn't come with the
baggage of who they were either positive
or negative made people focus on the
idea not person right and so that that
really allowed the idea to kind of
spread now you mentioned earlier um we
have Mark Andreessen we have Gary tan
kind of a whole host of people who are
kind of breathing you know uh life into
this movement it was already alive but
it's almost like pouring gas in the fire
like kind of blowing up a balloon right
where people are like okay if they're
interested in it maybe I should pay even
more attention how important is it for
these movements to get you know kind of
I'll call like Silicon Valley leadership
whatever the [__] that means at this
point but like to get them involved and
excited and tweeting about it putting it
in their bios all that type of stuff
no I think it's all it's all part of
legitimizing and broadening like I think
you start off um like any meme any idea
starts off like super super concentrated
small group of people who really believe
it and it's most just like it's like
deepest Core Essence or whatever it's
the most concentrated and then over time
it gets to a wider audience and as it
does you hope that it maintains those
core elements instead of just purely
diffusing like I think that if if I act
becomes purely just accelerationism if
it becomes purely just Tech is good like
if that's the ultimate takeaway from iak
that is like full dilution like full
diffusion like we didn't actually retain
the core elements of what it was in the
very beginning
um and so it's really it's important to
have these people that kind of
um not only uh you know sign on their
name like in this case it's literally in
their Twitter names you know Mark
Andreessen IAC or whatever
um but also kind of give it that
re-acceleration and that reinvigoration
to keep it close to its core as it grows
I mean like I'm a company Builder like
what I do for I'm a chief of staff at a
at a startup like my job is to make sure
that as we scale and as we get more
programs going for different satellites
around the world as we add more people
to our team that we retain the awesome
DNA that we had in the early days and
the you know the core of you know what
it is and what is the BET and what are
we like and how hard do we work and all
that sort of stuff
um naturally things diffuse entropy
takes over things you know Fade Out into
nothingness over time so you need these
people to not only sign their name and
like kind of give it legitimacy but also
to help reinvigorate it and keep it
close to that Core Essence so when you
think about uh IAC for AI what is the
the end result here right because I
literally when I wrote a piece uh
recently I was telling you before we
started recording that
um you know I've been talking about a
lot of these topics for a long time just
around like we can build our way out
like GDP growth is like one of my
favorites it's like everyone talks about
debt to GDP and they only focus on the
debt side like if we just jacked up GDP
growth like 20 a year which seems you
know unfathomable at this point but if
we did that like we could grow our way
out of the problem
um and so like maybe we can get to 20
because we get to like five or six like
maybe right and so uh I wrote the piece
and I explained kind of the EAC movement
all the stuff and all of the critics
were like the iak folks want to replace
humans with machines like [__] those
guys is that true like I guess like the
most bluntly is that true okay so there
are some guys there are some Anonymous
uh Eagle uh dudes out there or whatever
that that like the the end point of the
argument for them is like uh you know
hey we need to expand the reach of
Consciousness as far as we can
um it's really hard to put a human in a
spaceship and send it all the way from
the Sun so let's just put like a
computer in there a conscious computer
that we can send really far away from
Earth like I don't think I go that far I
don't think I don't think that's like
the the mainstream eak or whatever I
think that um why you hear that is
because the EF folks are the people that
are working at these super awesome AI
companies that are trying to build
general intelligence which some people
argue like whatever some Google engineer
already like fell in love with one of
these things like they're some folks
think that these things are conscious
and think that they're you know human or
human enough or something uh and I don't
know I think that's that's why you hear
it I don't think it's the I don't think
that's the part that'll stick when this
thing goes mainstream I don't think
it'll stick well I take the Google
engineer for example like is that a
machine problem or is that a person
problem like we got people doing weird
[__] all over the place right and like
uh you got to imagine that people fall
in love with all sorts of other people
but things too like what is the
difference between loving a person
loving a dog right what's the next thing
like like you can kind of look at it and
you're like you're getting closer and
closer yeah yeah and and again I'm not
saying that like loving your dog and
loving the machine is the same thing or
even that it's close on that Spectrum
but it's very obvious to see like
there's probably a group of people who
are like hey human and human okay got it
then eventually it was like human to
animal now you could argue that there
are people who absolutely love inanimate
objects like talk to a sports
memorabilia collector yeah about their
car or like the baseball bat that Mickey
man will use to hit a whole like people
are people are nuts so like in some
weird way loving the baseball bat or
loving the like quote-unquote
intelligent machine like actually maybe
the intelligent machine is like closer
to the human than the uh let me let me
let me throw this at you then so this is
this isn't quite like love but I think
that there's a decent argument to be
made that AI is sort of like the next
thing with intelligence creation so we
talked about it before it's like jeans
and then it's memes and then like what's
next like I think there's an argument to
be made in the the ex dudes would surely
make this argument which is that AI is a
new way of categorizing information and
a new way of gaining information and
basically a new way to pass it on so
today in our like meme world or whatever
like in order for me to teach a lesson
to my kid I have to like say the words
to them or like give them a book that
has it written down or whatever probably
one of those two things
um but in the future when we have open
AI at scale or whatever we have like
chat GPT seven or like whatever uh we
don't have to deliberately go to find
that information and pass it down
anymore the computers will basically
pass it down for us so today I go on
Google and I search uh you know how to
uh you know how to create a fusion
reactor or whatever like I have to go
through all those links there's probably
a lot of links on Google if I'm actually
going to figure out how to make a fusion
reactor
um but in the future when we have these
AI systems that have seen the entire
internet they've seen the entire scope
of everything humans have ever written
or uh you know posted
um it can go click on all the links for
me it can go to page like I max out and
maybe like page two of Google like if
you find me on page three how long have
I been there like hours but this thing
can go all the way down as many O's as
they're on Google can like go and click
on all the links and learn all the
things and then this spits out to me
this nice little summary and it says
step one go find a big magnet step
number two like whatever
um so I think that arguably uh the AI is
like the third wave of that intelligence
creation so maybe not all the way to
love maybe it's not fully conscious but
it certainly can be a much better way of
like passing down lessons to our kids or
you know learn helping us figure out how
we're going to like interact with the
world one of the pieces also that I
always kind of point to is like everyone
loves a binary situation they're like
okay humans or machines like we get one
or the other and uh if you want to
replace the humans with machines then
like you're a bad person right okay
maybe maybe not but like there is this
like Middle Ground of like what if we
have humans augmented by machines right
which right now you and I are augmenting
our conversation by being able to use
technology by being in two different
places like I think there's a lot of
people are like that's pretty cool
that's good right uh I Google but like
what is the difference between me being
able to just think and get the answer
versus having to physically type it out
it's inefficient for me to type out the
question on Google or hit these AI
models or whatever and so is that maybe
kind of the actual end uh you know kind
of uh game if you will of IAC is like
it's not about replacing humans it ends
up actually just being like this huge
augmentation that would make us much
more efficient much better probably
would make us happier in many cases and
also more productive which then has all
these you know great benefits to society
yeah absolutely I mean the core the core
ea uh the core ex thing is like let's
capture more energy and use more energy
so you know right now Humanity isn't
that great at consuming energy from the
Sun like I think it's like 77 of our
energy comes from all oil and gas and uh
like natural gas and coal so those are
three things that also got their energy
from the Sun they were plants or animals
or whatever like decomposed and turned
into oil and coal eventually
um but it captured that energy from the
Sun like billions of years ago so today
we only get maybe like what is whatever
20 of our energy from the Sun as it
lands on Earth some of that comes from
solar cells some of that comes from wind
some of that comes from you know like
water or like in the water cycle and
rivers and stuff
um but it's only 20 of our energy today
and that as a whole is like some some
tiny tiny tiny tiny fraction of the
total energy that's output by the Sun
and so if you think about it our entire
world everything we've built up around
us like this entire planet is contingent
is like is based on being able to use
energy like if we couldn't use any more
energy anymore none of this exists so I
can't do anything anymore so the EAC
argument is what if AI helps us capture
more energy if it helps us figure out
new ways to do better solar cells if it
helps us find ways to you know do fusion
power whatever like it'll help extend
the the scope and scale of human
consciousness to use that you know Elon
Musk phrase the scope of scale and human
consciousness will increase if we get
better at capturing energy
um and they want to go even further they
want to like capture stars and they want
to you know build like Dyson spheres
around Stars which allows taking more
the sun's energy whatever uh but uh the
the simplest answer is they want to
expand the amount of time that we can do
all this so it's even more than just
making us happy in the moment or you
know making sure that you know we have
better belts and shoes but it's like
let's make sure that 10 000 years from
now we have enough energy to still
survive once all the coal and oil and
whatever are gone so I'm going to give
you an example
um a company I invested in uh is varda
right so uh similar to kind of space
stuff that you guys are doing just in a
different way and when Delian first told
me he was like hey we should like send
up uh manufacturing uh facilities up to
space I was like haha like that's funny
let's go together and then he was like
no dude I think we should [__] do it
and I literally was like whatever man
like I'm I'm in just because you're my
friend and like that sounds awesome uh
but like I'm this is a write-off right
like we're definitely losing all this
money yeah like I mean just like like
maybe we'll like figure something out
along the way or like there's like some
launch technology or you know like
whatever uh as most of these things go
but like I do think that there's like I
don't know SpaceX and like each couple
of years there's been a couple of these
companies right where people are like
wait a second that was an insane idea
three or four years ago like we have a
thing in space right now that is
manufacturing a drug and then we're
gonna bring it back down to earth like
what the [__] is going on humans are
awesome right like that to me is almost
like the perfect example but it's not
controversial and for some reason AI is
so controversial compared to like hey
wouldn't it be awesome if we like send
things up to space manufacturing and
brought them back down uh to earth like
that's an insane idea too but for some
reason people are like excited and cool
with that and almost like uh I want to
learn more versus this AI thing just
seems to scare the [__] out of people
it's like why do you think it's AI
specifically is it the doomers have done
a great job of like kind of reaching the
mass audiences and like warning them or
is it just like it's something they
don't understand and can't wrap their
head around I wonder I wonder how much
of it is even just like you know we see
the doomers on Twitter but are they even
really out there in the real world like
I think if I went to my parents right
now and I was like what do you think of
AI they'd be like I don't know like is
that by Google or something like I think
most people are probably not thinking
about it and so but of the people
thinking about it other people thinking
about a AI I think most of the people
that use AI or like interact with AI
probably have a positive experience with
it like there are people like uh I don't
know there was this company that was
just sold the Thompson Reuters that's
basically like a legal assistant and it
like can look through all the different
texts of like all the different court
cases and all the different relevant
stuff and just give you give you stuff
to uh to help you be a better lawyer you
know like there's very simple
applications of AI that people don't
think of as like this crazy gonna
replace humans uh you know future all
like AGI thing um and they interact with
those all the time and we're using it
even though we don't know it right now
like in this video call like it's
cleaning up my voice or something like
who knows
um and I don't know I think most people
probably aren't doomers I think probably
the the doomers are the people who
they think that everyone else is going
into this blind they think like I've
seen the future I I am the you know I
know how this is going to go and it's
not going to go well the IAC argument is
the opposite of that they say I don't
know how this is going to go nobody
knows how this is going to go how could
we possibly like I can't predict that
they were going to create like varda was
going to create these space factories
before they thought it up like or I
would have done it you know what I mean
like we can't predict the future but we
can trust that we have the ability to
solve to save things if it like if this
space Factory goes way wrong like you
know we can fix it for the second
version that kind of thing
um so I don't know there's the one
argument is I know the future and it's
gonna be bad the other argument is
nobody knows the future let's make it
better together I like I think I'm on
that side I do wonder how much of the
Doomer like psychology is just like this
is a way for me to make noise and like
get attention and so it's like uh I want
to be famous versus if they sat down and
uh they said hey look I want to share
some thoughts with you and no one will
ever know that I'm like the Doomer right
would they still have the those same
thoughts like if you took away the
ability to gain attention and fame how
many people would still believe it there
will be some right for 100 for sure
there's some that are not doing it for
attention and fame but sometimes you see
the the arguments that people are making
are the things they're saying and doing
and you're like man I don't know if you
really believe what you're saying as
much as like you really are trying to go
viral and like get the attention
um and and the same I guess could be
true on the ex side as well but but it
just feels like
um the game of the internet right and
like of the attention economy has
created the incentives for people to
have more and more extremic views and so
the Doomer extreme view of like we're
gonna replace all the people and that's
horrible like somehow now has life and
people actually like take it seriously
yeah it is it is interesting I'm not
sure if it's asymmetric like I I think
that it probably works in both
directions where you have like the the
people who are like everything is
perfect and there's no there's no risk
in anything ever and they're rewarded
for that because it's a more extreme
view something like that
um and I actually think this is really
interesting in terms of the whole like
entropy thing that the uh that the EF
people bring up in general you know most
things in the world kind of Fade Into
nothingness and Fade Into You Know
disorder it seems like social media is
doing this thing with memes where it's
making them more extreme and more
pronounced and more concrete and I
wonder like I think that that's that's
part of it that people don't usually
appreciate which is that we are we are
creating new ideas and these new ideas
are gaining more you know staying power
because we can interact with each other
in this different way like me and you
probably never would have found each
other to talk with each other if it
wasn't for Twitter if it wasn't for the
internet uh and so you know 100 years
ago we never would have we never would
have talked but now we're talking about
these ideas and we're able to you know
explore them together so uh I don't know
I think it's a I think it's an innate
future of the internet I don't think
it's something that has to do with
either just the doors or the
accelerationists but um we're definitely
getting more extreme that's for sure
somebody has listened or watched this
and they're like cool this like
effective acceleration or something
sounds awesome I'm in what should they
do like what what is the what is the
call to action like what is the thing
that the IAC movement you know kind of
wants it to manifest the ideas into like
action in reality yeah it depends it
depends when you have the the like which
levers you have the ability to pull but
uh if you're an investor go invest in
projects that are trying to create you
know new energy production or new uh uh
you know new cool uh um like pushing the
the boundaries forward in whatever way
they want um if you're uh if you're an
entrepreneur or a person who wants to be
an entrepreneur move to Silicon Valley
come out here go come interact with
these people and start your own company
I mean I think the the calls to action
are just uh you know accelerate it's to
let's let's put the foot on the gas
let's try out of many different
experiments
um I actually had someone on Twitter uh
message me after I made that post about
yak and said hey I think this is really
cool can I join
it's not really how it works man like
I'm not in charge like I don't know uh
just if you want to do it do it uh and I
think that's kind of the whole the whole
thing the move the whole thing of the
the whole idea the idea isn't that you
have to get someone's permission it's
just go for it if people are already
acting that way it's like back in like
2017 or 2018 this guy was arrested and
like I think it was like the Bronx or
Brooklyn or something and he was selling
fizzy physical Bitcoins like like Chuck
E cheese coins and he was like selling
them out of like a baggie right and so
like of course like the internet you
know took it viral and uh I mean you
could definitely see there's gonna be
some [__] who's like oh yeah I'm gonna
create the EAC Association it's 20 a
month you know whatever which is the
exact opposite to your point of like the
of what the movement is like you don't
have to actually even know anyone else
to participate and it is really just
like accelerate in your own local
community your own life whatever and you
are contributing uh even if no one knows
about it
yeah exactly I mean it's the very it's
the very like it's actually kind of a
tough movement to describe and to
capture because the whole idea of the
movement is like there is no one answer
there is no one set thing that we all
have to commit to it's like let's just
try it let a million flowers bloom if uh
people want to find out more uh I'm
gonna send them to your Tweet which like
we can call it a tweet I think now it
also might be yeah it's in the middle of
like a or it could be a blog or it could
be a blog post like I don't know I put
it on I put it on substack to begin but
then like Twitter and sub stack are not
getting along these days and so it got
like I posted it in like five hours
later it had like 20 views and I was
like all right I guess you can't put
subset links in Suites anymore turns out
I hope one day that they play nice Elon
should have a sub stack I think that
Elon would do just fine yeah or or as a
shareholder in sub stack maybe Twitter
should buy Sub stack and then we could
all play nice together that'd be even
better there we go Craig all right where
can we send people to find you on the
internet if uh if they want to follow up
learn more uh or find uh or find the
tweet that you did yeah sure so I have
two things that I would send you to the
first one is uh just Twitter come go
find me on Twitter Christian Kyle uh
pronounced underscore Kyle Kyle uh or
you can go yeah I saw when I saw it I
was like man he really is gonna make
sure people know how to pronounce his
last name it improved it improved
pronunciation of like 100 most people
say Keel and I'm like fine whatever I
don't care but I just made pronounce
kyle.com and then it worked uh so
there's that's one way and then the
other way is I'm starting a new um uh
sub stack on this actually so I just did
it uh recently it's called against the
dying of the light uh for that classic
uh rage rage against the dying of the
light I think that's the the ethos of
fighting against entropy uh so find it
at Dying Light dot substack.com awesome
I'm gonna go sign up right now I
appreciate your time today uh I learned
a lot we got a couple of good laughs and
uh if anyone wants to find out more
about effective accelerationism just
remember one word accelerate accelerate
accelerate Christian I appreciate it
we'll do it again in the future
all right see you man